bonjour miguel marie-luce bonjour moss
viol temps vous êtes le tout nouveau
secrétaire national de bâtir le pays
martinique nouveau secrétaire national
depuis hier bâtir qui était en congrès
au haut à la ferme de pierre et de
l'inventaire pour renouveler son comité
national david zobda a succédé à pierre
samot à la présidence bâtir est donc
tournant de son histoire
effectivement remplacé bien çà mau la
tête de bâti d'ailleurs pierre sambou
qui a été donc à l'origine de ce parti
politique et david zobda aujourd'hui qui
parle qui prend le relais je crois qu'il
a été donc à la bonne école et avec tout
ce qu'on a appris deux pièces un mot je
crois que bâtir le pays martinique
encore de beaux jours devant lui alors
lesquels marie luce david zobda le
président depuis hier a dit que ce
congrès là et être congrès de
l'affirmation idéologique c'est quoi
l'idéologie de bâtir le pays martinique
et bien notre idéologie se constitue
aussi donc avec le quotidien donc du
peuplement unique et c'est à dire que
nous n'allons imposer quoi que ce soit à
nous trouver population mais bien au
contraire fait avec d'ailleurs le
congrès a défini hier donc cette ligne
idéologique 1 puisque nous savons
pertinemment qu aujourd'hui le paysage
politique monte inique et a changé et
que le peuple martiniquais bon comprenez
bien que je parle déjà de peuple
martiniquais a son mot à dire salut que
ce sera bâti et le peuple martiniquais
pour constituer vraiment ce qu'on
pourrait appeler de mais l'idéologie
donc de bâtir le pays martinique vous
avez évoqué de nouvelles orientations
parmi celles-ci définir un plan d'action
pour s'étendre
enfin sur toute la martinique bis
repetita des autres congrès de bâtir non
parce que jusqu'à maintenant
aussi si je vais y aura toujours une
autre l'intention de s'installer partout
en martinique
oui bah tiens n'y est jamais arrivée oui
c'est vrai c'est vrai parce que à
l'époque peut-être donc bâti est un
parti politique jeune et qu' il ya eu
beaucoup de chants de sirène beaucoup de
gens sont venus de partout
- miguel ma bulle ce moment donné donc
j'y croyais et après donc j'ai mis hou
liens politiques et j'ai compris que
c'était plus ou moins des personnes qui
venaient donc pouls des pauses doxa nous
en sommes quelque part affaibli et c'est
pour ça que quand david zobda réaffirme
knox
cette manière de faire cette nouvelle
manière de faire de la politique eh bien
on fera avec nous mobilité de base et
tous ceux et toutes celles qui viendront
de l'extérieur apportez donc un souffle
nouveau à bâtir eh bien nous allons donc
que les accueillir mais d'abord voir les
choses autrement
ce soin à part ici pas son que vous avez
su tirer du passé pour espérer réussir
cette fois ci non je pense que toutes
les mesures du passé donc permettent
donc avec lucidité de bâtir de bâtir est
donc exclue si on voit que ceux du thème
de bâtir donc un avenir meilleur et je
pense que on a attiré donc beaucoup de
leçons du passé et avec david zobda
nouveau président et moi même donc
secrétaire national donc de bâtir le
pays martinique
j'entends bien sûr après tout ce qui
était dire au congrès donc apporter donc
ce souffle nouveau à notre parti et
faire davantage de personnes donc aimer
la politique oui pierre samot josette
manin la députée ancienne présidente du
département david zobda vous est ce que
vous avez vraiment livrer la bataille de
l'idée politique du positionnement
idéologique au sein de bâtir pour
pouvoir rayonner sur toute l'île et bien
donc ce comme je vous le limoger le
temps hier au cours du congrès on a
quand même défini un certain nombre donc
deux lignes idéologiques de lignes
d'action parce que ce sont d'abord les
actions et qu'ils vont conduire c'est à
dire que déjà - david jobin arrive en
tant que nouveau donc président il a 2
il a des idées nouvelles
on a constitué donc un nouveau bureau
avec bien sûr comme je vous le dis car
il sentait que ce critère donc nationale
mais aussi il ya donc d'autres membres
du 2e tour de notre mouvement qui vont
au cours des semaines à venir autour
d'une table dans que travailler et
continuer parce que ces voiles
idéologique donc de bâtir se base sur
une certaine donc notion de peuple aussi
de souveraineté mais la souveraineté ce
ne sera pas une souveraineté imposé bien
au contraire nous déclinons que cette
souveraineté en plusieurs actes et comme
je vous l'aï dit précédemment lycées
avec le peuple martiniquais que nous
allons donc
bien sûr d'abord formation mixte
exactement la même chose miel marie-luce
ils disent mais ils disent mais nous
sommes nous sommes dans un système
politique actuel où on voit très bien
que les limites donc les limites donc de
la pensée mais nous à bâtir nous savons
donc pertinemment donc ce que nous
voulons et le moment le moment le moment
est donc venu nous soyons donc proposé
proposait donc à nos adhérents proposent
à nos militaires mais aussi proposer au
peuple martiniquais
donc ce que nous entendons faire de
cette souveraineté est ce que vous
n'avez pas perdu beaucoup d'énergie trop
d'énergie dans dans le fonctionnement de
cette alliance ensemble pour une
martinique nouvelle
écoutez donc toute expérience donc et
bonne aviv et au jour d'aujourd'hui
quand on fait le bilan je dirais qu'il a
été plus ou moins donc un bilan un peu
positive parce que vous pourrez désir la
caution là non parce que au sein de deux
camps quand je regarde des résultats si
je si je m'arrête par exemple aux
élections je vois que c'est bien entendu
au sein de da simplement think nouvelle
que nous avons à bâtir le pays
martinique est la première femme
présidente de conseil général après
c'est là c'est bien au sein donc de
cette alliance que nous avons pu aussi
avoir la première femme député de la
martinique
donc il n'y a pas eu que du négatif bien
sûr aujourd'hui il serait donc opportun
et pour que le nouveau président de
bâtir le pays martinique puisse
rencontrer donc 7 c les six personnes
qui forment cette alliance pour essayer
de de revoir les contours les contours
de cette alliance il a juste brillé que
nous permettrait donc d'apporter donc un
souffle nouveau pour cette matinée
justement finalement voyant ce moment
qui est en souffrance faut ici si vous
en parler en ces termes il ya une belle
lucy vous dis qu'il faut redéfinir les
contours de la leader c'est que vous
n'êtes pas à 100% content alors qu'est
ce qui ne va pas je n'ai pas dis qu'au
départ sont tous sont contents que je
veux autant bien au contraire je vous ai
dit qu'il y avait quand même de qui la
vit plus ou moins aux ya eu un apport
positif + ou - visites y faisant -
conditions - ce nom mais aujourd'hui on
voit bien que il y a donc certains
certains groupes un certain parti au
sein de cette alliance qui sont venus et
puis qui sont repartis donc en quelque
part ça ça c'est un fip de l'alliance
donc nous allons revoir les choses on
peut leur dire à socialiste de martine
jeune je ne citerai donc aucun aucun
parti mais
le constat est là qu il faut donc
reprendre les choses donc de mes deux
mètres et donc redéfinir comme je le dis
dans que ses contours pour ali donc vers
l'avant parce que je crois qu'elle a
menti ni qu on en a fortement besoin
hier david zobda parler de
fonctionnement de pmn sur socle
idéologique sur un volet politique sur
une cohérence et puis sous-entendus sur
des règles de fonctionnement beaucoup
plus clair ça c'est le président de bâti
de bâtir le nouveau no 2 de bâti de la
pluie bien sûr qu'ils qui le disaient
est bien bien bien entendu je suis
entièrement d'accord avec lui puisque je
suis en train de dire qu'il faut
effectivement donc se mettre à nouveau
autour de la table et on va définir et
ou repenser risques je sais que
aujourd'hui pertinemment on le voit un
lille il ya deux ou trois ans il y a
deux blocs politiques
peut-être qu'un troisième est en vue
mais en tout cas donc seul aucun parti
aucun mouvement politique ne pourra
aller donc vo qu'une bataille
et encore elle sera donc pas en position
d'offrir donc au peuple martiniquais
alors d'idées remis leur dites nous ce
que vous voulez au sein de pm n qu'est
ce que vous voulez qu'est ce que vous
mettez d'abord sur la table et qui
serait pas discutable pour vous non non
bien sûr donc dans les jours à venir
nous aurons à rencontrer donc les
partenaires de pmr et je crois que c'est
si ensemble ces lots d'oeufs de
deschamps de l'eau de discussion donc
fait un an que nous allons donc aboutir
nous avons des propositions à faire le
président de bâtir house a des
propositions à faire mes mots violents
excusez moi donc je ne saurais donc à
cet instant précis donc vous vous
révélez notre notre feuille de route
oh c'est donc la cendre on a des
conflits de demain comme un truc on a
bien compris qu'avec vous miguel
laventure on devra surtout attendre le
retour de david zobda qui est parti hier
soir pour david zobda una vida la sortie
du congrès d'hier à à la ferme de
perrine a évoqué un pessimisme ambiant
au sein de la population vous aussi vous
le ressentez comment comment lutter
contre ça puisque sans population il
ya pas d but politique et s'éveille il
suffit d'un suffit de regarder le
paysage politique actuel il suffit de
regarder donc la gouvernance du pays on
voit donc l'état dans lequel donc la
martinique se trouve comparativement à
d'autres départements qui malgré les
difficultés actuelles donc parviennent
donc à immerger donc un peu alors nous
ont menti ni combien voilà depuis depuis
quelques temps c'est une souffrance un
ça ça se lit ça se voit d'ailleurs il
suffit de il suffit de constater le
nombre de deux conflits sociaux donc qui
paralyse notre pays
et voilà c'est ce serait si nice devait
brady a lancé vers le politique qu'on se
tourne pourront essayer d'avoir une
réponse
qu'est ce que vous allez faire et ce que
vous comptez faire là dessus et bien
donc quand je disais que il faut
redéfinir les contours de mpm intérêt
dans cette matière de nouvelles et bien
c'est parce que nous avons donc cette
ferme volonté de reprendre les choses en
main de revenir au pouvoir pour donner
donc un peu plus de confiance donc
augmenter nikkei et faire en sorte que
notre coin de pays dans que puisse se
classer dans que parmi donc ce qu'ils
ont qu'ils ont à offrir donc un binette
mon corps est un de mes meilleurs donc
la population et défiance de la
population disait david zobda hier
besoin de participation si le constat
que tout le monde fait aujourd'hui alors
qui donc qu'est ce qu'on a envie et donc
et donc est donc bien et bien ça sera
fait et bien ceux qui ont le pouvoir en
mai donc je pense que monsieur
louiseville tôt il faudrait aussi donc
allez donc
ou bien les invités donc ici et leur
poser la question vous avez le pouvoir
qu'est ce que vous faites pour ce peuple
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour le pays
martinique donc il l'a dépeint les
fessiers les faits sont là les faits son
fils guérison c'est exactement la
question que je vous pose ce matin en
tant que secrétaire national de bâtir le
pays martinique
qu'est ce que vous allez faire pour
ramener un optimisme hausser de cette
population
comment vous allez combattre cette
défiance de la population et comment
vous allez surtout vraiment mettre cette
participation avec la population de
façon effective l'association et nous
allons commencer donc eux aussi
de notre partie bâti de piment tunique
comme je vous le dis donc nous allons
bien structuré notre notre nouveau
comité national nous avons des échéances
à venir nous allons faire en sorte que
la population nous suivent donc à
travers donc nos idées et nos
propositions gagner au fur et à mesure
les élections pour harry reid pour
arriver donc vous avez des gens de laver
les élections des prochaines élections
les prochaines élections dont les
européens minicipal entre elles et
municipales européennes et même et
surtout donc à la septième pour qu en
fait parce que à bâtir un peu on
pourrait avoir de très bonnes idées mais
tant que nous n'aurons pas donc le
pouvoir ne soyons donc les mettre en
pratique pour le bien de la population
de la martinique donc nous allons faire
en sorte que notre parti politique soit
soit bien structurée soit fort d'abord
déjà au lamentin faire en sorte que la
base de bâtir qui se trouve donc sur le
territoire de cette commune ne soit bien
6 et au fur et à mesure donc allez donc
au delà donc d'une amandine donc prendre
en considération l'agglomération mais
aussi donc tout de vente unique pour que
enfin la menthe unique avec avec avec
ensemble ou de motifs nouvelles et
puissantes jusqu'à maintenant nous
sommes donc aussi de cette alliance et
avec cette alliance nouée pendant chose
donc reprendre en main la chose
politique pour donner espoir au peuple
martiniquais dans cette alliance
ensemble pour une martinique nouvelle il
y aura forcément un axe très fort entre
le parti progressiste martiniquais et
bâtir qui sont les deux formations les
plus importantes de cette coalition
eh bien je voudrais donc ici d'un que
sous-entend une mesure autant dire que
voilà peut-être que ce qui fait mal aux
autres quoi partis ou mouvements qui
composent danser en martinique nouvelle
nous sommes nous sommes à ensemble pour
une martinique nouvelle nous sommes de
cette alliance et je ne voulais pas dans
que qu'en phase de classement de partir
de mouvements
donc c'est une alliance composée donc de
de plusieurs partis de plusieurs
mouvements et c'est ensemble donc avec
eux et qu'on va converger donc vers la
veille de nouvelles victoires pour
programmer les a fait du bien vous êtes
en train de nous dire que le ppm devrait
faire attention à son but son envie
d'hégémonie jeunes eux non je ne vais
pas donc jusqu'à vous vous et profitez
en mais quand on est dans une alliance
donc si vrai on a six forces mais aussi
on a ses faiblesses donc et je crois que
pour comme une excuse fonctionner donc
on doit mettre de côté son ego et faire
en sorte que on soit donc au même niveau
tous deux atteints merci d'avoir été ce
matin avec nos miguel marie-luce depuis
hier sur international de bâtir le pays
martinique merci bonne journée